it's a big big question it's not easy so
the Davos question has been asked hello
da those people the DeVos question hi
devil States today I would like to
mention this Devils question the Davos
question I'd like that the Davos
question of questions i'm replying to
the davos question do you think that
countries companies or individuals must
do to make the world a better place
2008b there's different countries
different companies and different
individuals sidelined by six billion
assigned you know six billion with a
beach this is gonna be for a phones
gonna have different answers low two
loads and loads and those of difference
because everyone got their own
individual perspective of how they see
things and how they see the world we
need to find a way to stop the poverty
rate from going up and make it go down
why does our world not have a safe blood
supply covering the globe with the
high-speed two-way that's where we got
to go invest in kids water shortage will
be a key challenge facing the world in
the first half of the 21st century by
investing in renewable energy perhaps we
can save many of the species that are
dying because of the impact we caused to
the environment but more importantly we
will also avoid struggles and war and is
that not what we want for our children a
world in which we can work together in
peace as a writer as an MP I think that
everybody the world is committed improve
the state of the world we
to be able to communicate the best that
we can from generation to generation and
build upon the past and improve upon the
past try to open your mind to what other
people are saying and let's share our
ideas and let's progress